dove vai non ci può andare in bagno
perché appena pulito e scappa palla in
giardino professoressa lo schifo che ho
trovato in quest'aula è inspiegabile
fazzoletti mascherina di tutto fatemelo
dire siete proprio dei maiali vi dovete
vergognare bidella ci chiami tua madre e
io sono collaboratrice scolastica lo
puoi anche leggere qui
ma io dico a casa vostra scrivete sui
banchi per caso io che avviso se vi
vedono altra volta fumare nei panni vado
direttamente a dirlo alla presina non mi
interessa e non mi volontà ed ai maya
siete proprio delle scostumate voi
ragazzi ed oggi tutte scosciate mano e
che ne so io dove la prova mica sono un
centro informazioni
cosa vuoi finita la carta igienica
aspetta un attimo e rischia di spazzare
tutto corridoio poi te lo porto ai mal
di pancia
adesso ti porto un po di chiacchio e ti
passa tutto tranquilla e tu che ci fai
in giro tira subito glassa